you are watching :
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
together here so former CEO of Apple
John Sculley is starting his own phone
company so what exactly is going on here
let's take a look at the back story in
the late 1970s John Sculley was a
successful marketer turned CEO at
PepsiCo in the early 1980s Steve Jobs
wanted to apply Scully's marketing
prowess to sew personal computers while
Jobs pursued his Mac mission he needed a
more orthodox chief executive to run the
company
a respectable face who could sell to
corporate America he chose Pepsi Cola
executive John Scully Scully refused
leave Pepsi for a four-year-old company
that had been set up in a garage are you
serious
but it was hard saying no to Steve Jobs
and then he looked up at me and just
stared at me with this there that only
Steve Jobs has and he said you want to
sell sugar water for the rest of your
life or do you want to come with me and
change the world and I just sculpt
because I knew I would wonder for the
rest of my life you know what I would
have missed Scully with a solid business
background and considerable recent
success would give Apple an image of
greater reliability and stability which
they needed at that time according to
insiders there's a fallout between jobs
and Scully that happened during the
development of the Macintosh
according to author Alex Dutchman jobs
created his own team to build his own
product the Macintosh his team actually
had his own building and became a
company within a company
the Macintosh team competed with other
parts of the company that actually made
money because of this a power struggle
erupted between Scully and jobs
in the spring of 1985 Apple's Board
sided with Scully the CEO at the time
and removed jobs from his command at the
Macintosh Group this stripped him of his
responsibilities and by the summer of
1985 Steve Jobs was no longer a part of
AB
as we know Jobs returned to Apple in
1997 and the rest is history but today
there's a very strange epilogue to this
story John Sculley now aged 76 is
creating his own phone the name of this
new phone the OB world phone the plan
for Scully is basically a mid-level
low-cost phone with two models running a
skinned version of Android skully being
a businessman has already noticed the
Western market saturation so Obi is
following hot on the heels of Google's
Android one that is they're targeting
the emerging markets the phone's target
market is bias 25 years and younger in
the emerging markets of Asia Africa and
the Middle East a cheap cost and
inspiring design isn't all Opie is
relying on themselves being nimble to
differentiate themselves against Apple
HTC and Samsung and subsequently give
themselves a fighting chance in this
industry as some of you who have been
subscribers of this channel might
remember in my Nokia documentary it was
the large size of Nokia which led to a
ton of bureaucracy and ultimately a slow
reaction time that aided in the demise
of the telecommunications giant being a
small private company Obie has the
ability to quickly iterate designs and
swap out new components if it believes
that will be beneficial to their
business and that's a real advantage in
such a tightening market let's hear a
bit from John Sculley himself are you
trying to remake the iPhone we're really
inspired by the tremendous success that
Apple has had with the iPhone but Apple
is really not a competitor to us are we
to them what has happened is that
technology is so commoditized that it's
now possible to build a high-quality
smartphone where we can differentiate
with great design i brought together the
head of apple's product design when I
was there Robert Brunner who originally
hired Johnny Ives we can sell at price
points way below anything Apple would
ever be interested in and we can appeal
to the emerging markets we'll never have
much interest to sell in most of Europe
or in the United States because these
are replacement markets with strong
competition but we're focused on the
emerging markets markets where we have
all
a billion dollar supply chain a nike
distribution business so we have some
familiarity with the sales channels and
we believe that we can reach out to
first-time buyers who may have the
aspiration for these higher priced
products but they don't have the
personal budget we wouldn't be
interested in doing this even if we
weren't moving into a market that is
going through exceptionally high growth
if you're going into a market where you
have to take your business away from a
competitor that's really hard and
especially with great competitors like
some of the Chinese companies but if
you're going into a market which is
growing at incredible rate of growth as
we're seeing in the emerging markets of
where you've got new young consumers
coming in who are looking for products
that can have aspirational design to
them but at attractive price points we
don't need to get a very big market
share in order to be able to build a
very attractive business for ourselves
remember we're a private company were
not a public company and so our
ambitions may be quite different than
some of the large public companies all
right so let's talk a little bit about
the specs the flagship baby world phone
call to sf1 has a 5-inch 1080p display
with 4G LTE and a flash on both the
front and back cameras with a Snapdragon
615 processor
it's priced at $1.99 for two gigabytes
of RAM and 16 gigabytes of storage or
249 for three gigabytes of RAM and 32
gigabytes of storage the cheaper Obi
world phone the SJ 1.5 comes with 3G
immediate tech quad core processor comes
in multiple colors and has a 720p screen
the phone is $129 for 16 gigabytes of
internal storage both phones have dual
SIM slots expandable SD storage up to 64
gigs and 3000 milliamp hour batteries
the phones will be available in October
and will launch both online and in-store
so what can we make from all of this
well seemingly it really does seem that
John Sculley has the right idea a low
price a different choice of specs
depending on your budget a red-hot
emerging market and a small nimble
company that can make changes when
needed
although it seems like a bee is a budget
version of the Chinese company oneplus
they could still be seeing some success
in a largely untapped market we'll have
to wait and see and keep an eye on how
this goes
anyway so that was just a story that I
thought was really interesting and kind
of highlights with a slight tone of the
mobile industry is starting to go so
this has been to gogo you've been
watching cold fusion give it a thumbs up
if you liked it or thumbs down if you
didn't leave a comment and subscribe if
you're new oh and by the way if you want
to know more about Android or iOS and
want to know the differences between the
two you and want to see the histories of
both of them then you can check out my
previous videos on Android versus iOS
they'll be the first links in the
description below thanks a lot for
watching guys I'll see you again soon
for the next video Cheers have a good
one